es oficial la policía metropolitana de
londres a multar aa boris johnson el
primer ministro estará entre las 50
personas sancionadas por las famosas
fiestas ilegales de downing street en
pleno confinamiento pero johnson no está
solo en esto junto a él están carrie
johnson su esposa y reyes una el titular
del ministerio de economía británico
algo por lo que la oposición laborista
ha pedido su dimisión
boris johnson y risas una a cambio la da
la ley y han mentido repetidamente al
público británico ambos deben renunciar
los conservadores son totalmente
incapaces de gobernar reino unidos se
merece algo mejor es la primera vez en
la historia de reino unido que un primer
ministro en ejercicio tiene una
amonestación penal aunque está hacia el
leve los multados deberán pagar en torno
a 120 euros aunque según los expertos lo
más grave es la nueva mancha en la
reputación del político conservador y su
gabinete de las 12 fiestas celebradas
durante el confinamiento se le relaciona
con seis una de ellas por su propio
cumpleaños en junio de 2020
estoy contento de que finalmente haya
pasado debería haber sido multado hace
mucho tiempo básicamente eso ha sido
demasiado tiempo y no creo que la multa
sea suficiente él ha hecho muchas más
fiestas que cualquier otra persona él
rompió las normas más severamente que yo
y además es la persona que establece las
normas el líder del país roses
aunque los expertos estiman como
improbable una nueva fisura entre los
conservadores es muy probable que boris
johnson deba volver a la cámara de los
comunes a dar explicaciones ya que
muchos ciudadanos especialmente los
familiares de las víctimas de kobe 19
están indignados por el comportamiento
del mandatario